-Well, guys, today is
the last day of February,
so I thought it would be nice to
give a little recap
of the entire month.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ February came and went ♪
♪ The shortest month,
but I feel spent ♪
♪ 28 days gone so soon ♪
♪ Kind of like... ♪
-The Chinese spy balloon.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Grammys, BAFTAs, Oscar noms ♪
♪ "Top Gun" did it,
good for Tom ♪
♪ Whether or not you win
that bling ♪
-♪ Angela Bassett
did the thing ♪
♪ Super Bowl won by the Chiefs ♪
♪ Eagles fans were
filled with grief ♪
♪ Rihanna's halftime
we were lovin' ♪
♪ She did it with a... ♪
-Bun in the oven.
♪ Biden gave his big address ♪
♪ State of the Union
in Congress ♪
♪ Republicans shouted
from their chairs ♪
♪ Angrier than a... ♪
-Cocaine bear.
♪ Valentine's did not go great ♪
♪ You got stood up
by your date ♪
♪ Tinder tells you that
you should think about... ♪
-Retiring for good.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Marvel's "Quantumania" ♪
♪ "Last of Us,"
"Outer Banks-ia" ♪
♪ We watched them all
except our aunts ♪
♪ Who were drooling over... ♪
-♪ "Magic Mike, The Last Dance."
-♪ February, you short king ♪
♪ Here comes March,
it's time for spring ♪
♪ We'll lose money on
our brackets ♪
♪ Then get trashed on
St. Patrick's ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪